Have I ever advised anyone not to crowdfund?
Yes, not to say that they won't be successful
in crowdfunding at all but they aren't ready yet I
mean the biggest question is how much do you think
I can raise I don't know how big is your online
audience cuz you're going to need them in order
to raise money so if you have never stepped foot
into the online space you really don't know how
that Twitter thing works or you don't even have
your own personal profile on Facebook it's whoa
okay you're not even close to being ready to start
a Kickstarter campaign first you need to get that
first you need to get that piece going first you
need to be used to connecting with an audience
I'm not saying you need millions of people but
you need a a core group of people because those
are the ones who are going to help you to spread
out you're not going to be able to spread word
of mouth all by yourself you're going to have to
have a group of people to do that and it's going
to be dependent on how active those people are
and how many are they as to how much money you
can raise you know and and there is no figure if
you have 5,000 followers you should be ra able to
raise $30,000 I no I don't know there are people
who have 5,000 followers and only a 100 people
gave money so 30,000 is not going to you know
if they give $10 a piece you're going to get a
couple thousand you know you're not there's also a
huge correlation between the number of people who
are lurkers and the people who actually will take
money out of their wallet and give it to you and
in presentations that I give I show Freddy Wong as
an example he's you know on YouTube and is raised
two times on on Kickstarter significant amounts
of money but if you look at how many follow
subscribers Freddy Wong has on his YouTube channel
it's 4.7 million subscribers so you would think oh
he can raise Millions only 10,000 of those people
gave money in any degree in his last Kickstarter
so it was very lot less than what he had as his
follower so we were talking about in this these
recent Canadian Workshops the 991 rule which Julie
Giles talks about she's from green hat digital
and she said 90% of your following are lurkers
they're people who are just watching they never
participate they've clicked your page and of like
and they've never come back or they just see you
in the news feed and they never do anything about
it 9% of those people will retweet you will put a
thumbs up next to a comment or leave a comment
but they're not tight to you you know they they
participate but they're not they aren't going to
convert only 1% of your supercore hardcore fans
will ever do anything to help you that actually
actively spread the word support everything you
do pay money to go to your events show up if you
have a meet up that kind of thing so when you're
looking at your stats online and you think that
all all those 5,000 people are a sale you'll be
very disappointed when it when push comes to
shove about how many people actually Pony up
for the money so I would say that if you haven't
even gotten started no no kind of crowdfunding
effort should be started if you have gotten
started you're going to have to be realistic
it's better to go over your goal than it is to
not make your goal so set it realistically you
know how much do you really need to do what it is
and is is that the main goal behind this campaign
is it to raise money or is it mainly to to build
an audience to to build up that participation and
and money is nice but that's not the main idea
behind this effort is to to grow beyond your
core because a campaign like that usually helps
you to to get more people beyond the the people
that you're already engaged with because they
help you and there's an impetus to it because
there's a deadline as opposed to constantly saying
hey you know retweet my stuff hey share my stuff
you know that that's just kind of an arbitrary
effort if you have a campaign where there's a
deadline and you're all working towards some kind
of you know goal then there's reason to activate
those people in a certain time frame and that's
what a campaign is you know it's it's a limited
amount of time that you're doing some effort
if if money is your only thing then you're
going to have to be careful about how much you're
asking to raise because it depends on how helpful
the audience that you already have is going to
be to you I thought about it I felt I feel to
successful I I really believe in crowdfunding in
a lot of ways I feel for it to be most successful
you need to have the support of everyone involved
and for me David's been Inc like Beyond supportive
like overwhelmingly supportive of the project
but he wasn't a producer on the film he you
know he would say this too he's not he wasn't
interested in the process he wanted to let me
go make it and I sort of felt to run a successful
crowdsourcing campaign for it it would have needed
his involvement cuz I felt it would have been sort
of disingenuine to be the way to run a successful
campaign would have been like hey Sedaris fans you
want to see a Sedaris movie and it felt what sort
of I didn't feel comfortable asking him maybe
he would have helped me and done a video I'm
not sure but I didn't it felt wrong to ask him
you know for me and I felt without his support
it felt sort of wrong to run a campaign for it
now that there's a finished film if I had we you
know we've closed distribution so I but if I was
doing a self-distribution I would consider it now
that there's a finished film and now that I have
interviews with David and elements I can use with
his permission of course but but I feel like it's
each each Project's its own and some projects are
meant to be crowdfunded and and this one just
wasn't wasn't one of them I didn't feel like
I could engage the community in the right way and
also we had some actors attached but they ended up
not being the actors in the final film and I felt
like we would have needed to utilize them but I
felt uncomfortable with that because I didn't have
a working relationship with them yet and they were
you know slightly bigger names than what ended
up in the movie Just by the nature of whoever
at the time I cast them they weren't bigger names
and they got bigger names and got too busy to be
in the film and I ended up with a cast could have
only dreamed of having anyway so I'm I'm thrilled
about that but it felt strange to bring them
involved it just didn't feel like I could do
it the right way and I feel like when they look at
the really successful crowd crowd campaigns sure
there's some outliers that go into the three and
$400,000 but I really feel like the most ambitious
you really should get you know is to expect is at
the most you know 100 you know I feel like even
the Canyons I think they ended up going to like
130 but you have Paul Shader and Brett Easton
Ellis who each have massive loyal decades long
fan bases and even then they pushed a lot on that
campaign and you know they hit which is incredible
amount of money but that still wasn't enough for
me to make the film so I also felt uncomfortable
going out there and being like give me $100,000
and maybe I'll be able to find the other however
much we need it it it just felt wrong for this
project but I hope I can do something one day that
I can make cheaply enough you know this movie had
to be shot on location it had 30 speaking Parts
it had you know a different location every day
all exteriors it just had things that naturally
made it expensive and but I hope to do something
if I did something small if I did a movie I could
shoot on my own and with minimal crew and minimal
locations and here in Los Angeles I would I
would totally consider doing crowd sourcing that
way so here's the deal everybody that I talk to
about crowdfunding right it's called crowdfunding
I my assertion is that it should be called
something else because everybody thinks
that the maximum benefit of crowdfunding is of
course funding right get your money and that's
true that's a benefit and it's a big benefit and
it's important right but there's also a wholly
unappreciated sort of dynamic that happens when
you crowdfund okay backing up the old way the old
way of Distributing the old way of raising money
before crowdfunding existed you know thousands of
days ago right was you would have two ways that
you could get an audience to raise their hand
that they're a fan of your right there was buy
the DVD we're talking about films now okay theyd
either buy the DVD or go to the theater right
and in those two ways it was binary themselves
of whether they would raise their hand they
would either buy it or they would not buy it
so you would make your film for two years right
and you might tell your audience that it's coming
there's going to be a way you can help us out
just when the DVD comes or inin theaters and
go buy that ticket or buy that DVD and then when
it happens they can either pay1 bucks for the the
ticket of the theater or not pay or they can pay
20 bucks for the DVD or not pay that's it so there
are three kinds of audience members all right
there is the first kind that is the person who
might have heard about the film might have been
interested in the film maybe you had something
on the web maybe there was an ad and they're like
okay I think I will see that film but just on the
merits of the film what they heard they'll go okay
kind number one kind number two is I don't know
about this film but I like Karen I like her style
I like her work I will see this movie because I
like that other thing she did so they're fans of
you and they're not so sure about the movie but
they'll go because of you that's kind too right
then there's kind number three which is I don't
care what you do I'm giving you money to do it I'm
G to help you do it I'm G to come do it I'm your
mother I'm your brother I'm your husband I'm your
son I'm you know whatever those are your fanatical
unconditional helpers okay so you got one two and
three right in the old way you didn't know which
was which you couldn't get in touch you couldn't
differentiate your fan base you didn't know some
people just came because they wanted to see the
film some people came because they saw your old
film and some people came because they would do
anything you tell them right so in the new way oh
and finally those three people all had one option
they could either buy it or not buy it so if they
kind of wanted to see it but weren't sure and then
they bought they just paid 10 bucks if they really
wanted to see it they pay 10 bucks if they were
crazy about you and totally would see anything
you did they paid 10 bucks now they might pay
10 bucks twice and buy someone else a ticket or
pay 10 times and give someone else you know 100
people tickets or whatever you know buy a bunch
of DVDs for people but they only could do that
thing right the revolution of crowdfunding and
again I think it should be called something else
is that now you can pull all of those people all
the way into your process starting the moment you
think I should make a movie right and so now you
go out to your immediate community and that of
course includes the number threes your mom your
sister your brother whatever it might include
your the number twos right which are people who
saw your other film so you have a list it probably
could include number ones because through doing
your other things you have some people who might
be interested in the film you're just thinking
of right but now what you're offering isn't hey
I'm gonna make this movie and someday pay me 10
bucks to go see see it in theater or give me 20
bucks for a DVD now what you're suddenly doing is
you're unsealing all of the value in the creation
of the artist artistic peace there's value all the
way from the moment you start thinking about
it to the moment you have that DVD or or the
ticket right and that value exists in people's
interest in the subject their interest in you
or they just fanatical support of any of those
things the subject or you or you know or your
career so now what you can do is when you have
the idea you say hey I'm thinking of making a
romance in Italy okay and it's going to be about
about two old people okay they're you know senior
citizens so I'm really excited and so you start
sharing that in your social network now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna say anybody who wants to be
involved in this way or that way or the other way
can by sharing with me something you have which
is maybe money or time and in exchange I'm going
to give you the experience of creation of that
thing that you love everybody who's a fan of
romance movies everybody who's a fan of Italy
movies everybody who's a fan of movies about
senior citizens and of course everyone who's a
fan of me right so you can give perks based on
the experience of creation so you can say hey
we're gonna have an opportunity you can you can
get in communication with people about what should
the film be about I have this idea and that idea
you can start communicating with all these people
you can start offering hey if you want your name
to be the name of the you know hotel that the the
the main characters have dinner at it'll cost 150
bucks you can come on the set you can hang out
people start to get excited and be involved then
what you start to do is through the process of
you also there's also back up there's also ways
that you can offer an experience of meeting you
and meeting all the other people involved maybe
there's fans of the actors maybe there's people
you're going to shoot on location in Italy maybe
you can say for this amount of money join us on
location in Florence and and you know that cost
you 2,000 bucks you charge 8,000 bucks maybe
people really love you and it has nothing to
do with the movie but they love you so you say hey
I'm going to cook you dinner and that's 600 bucks
whatever pick a number the point is that what it
Taps into is human beings desire to be involved
in an artistic Endeavor that takes years but they
don't have years they might be an accountant or a
lawyer or you know they were a mom and they just
made that choice but they want to touch the film
making process and they want to touch the people
they're fans of and they can pay for it and they
will because before all they could do was pay 10
bucks to go to a theater right or 20 bucks to buy
a DVD but now they can pay more and they can have
their their name involved they can be involved
with someone they love they can be involved with
the whole process of movie making or specific
kinds of movie making and so what that does at the
end of the day after You' figured out all those
things that you can offer and as a perk and get
all these people involved is you've moved people
who are casually interested the number ones into
number threes right where they are crazy about
you because they're invested in the film they have
their name on the hotel they were on set they know
all the actors they know the guy who does services
this is their movie and so what happens is by the
time that you get to the end of production which
in the old days was where you would start even
trying to find audience what do you have you
have all of these fans first of all who never
would have even been involved with you then you
have of those fans a giant number of number ones
which would have been maybe I'll see the movie
they're shifted over to I'm a wild and rabid
fan of you like your mother and what happens then
the day that you release they're all ready they're
locked and loaded not just to buy the ticket
which they would have done but to evangelize
about the film this is their film so suddenly
you don't just have your network you don't just
have your list from your old movie you don't just
have your actor's lists you have all of the lists
of all of the people that ever got involved in the
whole two years of your pre-production production
post-production that have been paying for the
opportunity to do it so you have a new Army of
evangelists for your film the day it comes out
into distribution that have paid you for the
opportunity to be there that is the Revolutionary
benefit of crowdfund Gary I'm curious why you
turned to Kickstarter to self-publish your book
why not go a more traditional now it was a process
actually it was it was it was an educational
learning curve for me it took me a while to
figure out that I didn't want a publisher that I
did want to self-publish and the relevant reason
primarily is I really wanted Manifest Destiny I
wanted to own my own intellectual property and
not give it up and not be on a royalty basis with
a publisher who wasn't going to Market it anyway
I thought you know what I really cuz I care deeply
about what's in the book it represents 25 years of
my life and I've always been in love with the
storytellers with the creatives and I want to
get this information out so I thought if I own it
I'm more free to do that in more innovative ways
so number one I thought I'm going to self-publish
the Second Step was then how do you self-publish
it's a very fast shifting landscape this world
of publishing it it's it's every day it's it's
changing by the hour and I I thought about I
thought okay I I've decided some things that are
good for me and there's a lot of moving parts so
I thought okay I'm going to hire layout designers
and people to e format it and book cover design
it and I'm going to hire a printer and order a
certain book run and on and on it there's a long
laundry list right I thought you know what if
I do all that that's great I'll have a beautiful
book and no audience and I have to start from from
zero then I just then I thought I started these
conversations asking people about crowdsourcing
crowdfunding in particular about Indiegogo about
Kickstarter and I realized Kickstarter really was
a phenomenal opportunity not just because and
and and and the least of it was the fundraising
what was most interesting to me was I get this
period of time over which to build a community I
get to find my brand evangelist I get to really
put my message out almost serialize it right
over time and drive traffic from all quarters from
traditional media and my database and other people
to this place called Kickstarter and it's very
Dynamic so this to me was the perfect Community
Building opportunity preed pre you know just
till the soil right how much pre-planning did
you do before you launched the campaign and what
sources did you go to to gather information on
crowdfunding well I have a my my partner Morgan
is very astute about social strategy so she knew
a fair amount about it to begin with I did not I
had to sort of study from the beginning and but
she brought me up to speed fairly quickly and then
we just asked a lot of people who we'd seen doing
it that we we had contacts to and you just Google
and you you know today how do you learn you Google
and you ask people and you you get on social media
and you ask people but it became very clear that
Kickstarter was the platform that was the best
fit for us and and I'll be honest with you you
know it's it's not quite as neat and clean as you
would hope you use your best judgment you go with
your gut because I think your gut is your best
guide for this kind of a social experience it's
not a sales job you can't you just it's got to be
about something something bigger than that so it
felt like if we just stay if we really vulnerable
and honest and candid and and committed to what
we're doing and put that message out whether it's
the video or the copy or however we present our
choice of our ways of saying thank you the perks
that we put together the people that we enrolled
from my film industry Community to be a part of
that if we created that as the ethos the fabric
of who we are and what we're doing and we stayed
true to that how bad could we fail so that's how
we began was just sort of seated the pants and
we've learned so much every week and it's only
been two weeks into the campaign we've learned
so much well it looks like what you're almost
80% funded or something we we're we're just 90%
funded and we're about halfway through and now we
just did a Twitter tweet-a-thon today and we're
getting some traditional media to drive traffic
to it over the coming 10 days or week and I I
think we're learning how to not sustain energy but
actually build it and create a bigger conversation
and bring more invite more people in and what's
interesting is how much people are ready to say
yes people really like to be part of this kind
of open conversation about something they deeply
care about and not they don't deeply care about
it because it's necessarily screenwriting and
they're not a screenwriter it's about creativity
it's about seeing people realize in this case
maybe it's even and seeing me realize a dream
of mine there's something that really tugs at
people about that and it's cool you know what
it's one of those things you don't want to go
back to the well very often and I know because
when I did it and when you guys did your good by
promise the first campaign we we were like way
in the beginning of of the whole phenomena where
people were really really interested and giving us
attention from a lot of film blog sites and people
just Dona because of the novelty of it they wanted
to see it succeed but now again in 2013 there's
one every day from somebody new and somebody you
like somebody you know and it's just hard to to
keep up and try to you know support everyone I
think I if I were to do it it wouldn't be for any
significant amount it it's obviously nowadays it's
a marketing tool you see a lot of people doing it
that get noticed in film festival programmers say
they actually scour the crowdfunding websites as
well so if I were to do it it'd be something for
just you know a smaller nominal thing where
I know I can make it but it's mainly just to
market the whatever project I'm I'm working on
and that's probably the only time I would unless
of course you never say never you know the
situation comes up like this is the only way
and I'm going to give it a shot and you know and
you think it's been enough time between projects
where you have enough a new fan base where it's
not the same old people then you know never say
never work you were able to raised 75,000 on
Kickstarter in 3 days for your space command
project what was your strategy when you launched
this campaign and then what did you find worked
and what did you find did not work MH well
you know I've sold over 100 scripts all of
the studios and the networks and in those cases
I didn't have to raise the money for instance
when I was a producer on sliders we had a 22
episode order our budget was 1.3 million per
episode I didn't have to raise that money so
although I knew I could run write and I know
I can write and direct and produce I'd never
raised funds before I didn't know if I would
succeed so the first thing I did was I treated
it as a as something new I had to learn and I
spent several months talking to people learning
how to do it building a team shooting the video
and really putting effort into the video because
that would be you know what I'd be using to show I
could do the project and but I didn't know if it
would work I didn't know if I could raise money
at all and now we're up to 158,000 we still have
several week you know a number of weeks ago we're
going to be having a panel at ComiCon so there's
we're 158 is not our final number by any means
and so so what I basically did was I realized I
had to treat it with respect and but I welcomed
that I welcomed learning a new thing but I had no
assumption that I would succeed and going in with
that attitude actually was very helpful because
then it became a continual learning process and
and and the main thing I also knew was that you
had to be in direct communication day by day
with your backers with your audience you couldn't
just it's not pushing the big red button and then
you know walking away that that's I think why a
lot of people F did you research other campaigns
what was your sort of due diligence yeah well
fortunately I run a round table of writers and
directors and actors and producers and we meet
every Thursday and we've been doing that for
19 years and it's several thousand people and
so I put out the word on to my table saying if
anyone knows about Kickstarter please send me
information so I got a lot of response and so
I started researching successful campaigns like
double fine and some of the things Neil Gaiman
was doing and and then ultimately Neil showed
me the campaign that his wife Amanda Palmer
was doing and so I was learning from that and and
then just kind of course correcting as I went and
some things you do don't work and some things you
do work and and then also you build a team and so
when show someone shows up who wants to help first
of all you find out what their skills are and then
you say okay well let's see if they're actually
going to do it rather than just talk about doing
it and and what's really also amazing is how fast
everything is there's instantaneous response and
so it could be a 24/7 job if you let it but you
also have to not get exhausted because you have
to keep a clear head to be able to do your job how
much time went into pre-planning a couple months
two or three months yeah and and that was both
shooting the video and also just you know reading
up on Kickstarter talking to people learning and
but also we actually launched about a month later
than we intended simp because we had to do make
some further tweaks and we were we finding the
project because also that's the other part of
it you're also working on the project as well
the the the series of films and you're developing
the concept builds and grows and people will give
you input and then you so you you're responsive
to that it really is a very direct U two-way
conversation and the video is excellent thanks and
I'm wondering how much time you put into planning
that because you have so many elements in it you
have the personal element where we you and other
people in your Ensemble but then you also have
the fun stuff in the background and all of the
the other work that you've done well it was it was
we put a couple months in on on the video and part
of it one thing I recognized with Kickstarter that
was very very clear is that you have to have the
Personal Touch it's the person the individual
saying hi this is who I am I really would like
your help it's usually one person whether it's
double fine or Amanda Palmer It's usually the the
the one-on-one and fortunately I was a commentator
on Morning Edition for 3 years long ago and I've
done a lot of media interviews and so I'm very
comfortable with that and I think that helped
but also in my campaign it was me as a person
but it was also this is the body of work I've
done and then the third part is this is the team
I've I've assembled and it's an amazing team and
then it was the special effect shots that we were
generating fresh saying this is what what we're
doing is going to look like so it wasn't just you
can look at our work from the past but there's no
Talent what we're going to do now here's something
very concrete that we generated new specific to
this project and that was very important because
otherwise people are going to be dubious but if
you say okay look look at this if you like this
if you like these effect shots if you like these
actors who are going to be casting then you get
a pretty good idea about what we're up to how did
you choose your incentives that took a long time
to in terms of choosing the incentives we looked
at other campaigns we thought about ourselves
as as Geeks and we'd like CU When I was a kid
Star Trek debut the original Star Trek and I was
a huge Star Trek fan and and they they were very
slow in terms of merchandising products from
Star Trek initially there were very few and I
longed for different you know model kits and and
action figures and toy phasers and all that stuff
so I was just kind of thinking about me as a fan
and and what would appeal to me and what would
I like to have and what would be interesting and
it was a mixture of several things because I was
thinking about the different kind of people who
would be pledging to space command and so there
would be the fans who were just science fiction
fans they they'd love to be part of this and
maybe get a space command watch or space command
jacket then there were also the people who might
be visual effects people and maybe they want to
be part of the team or they want to learn from
what we're doing so there's also the the howto
aspect so I actually posted something called the
one minute film school that's about how you pitch
a script how you you know write write a movie how
you direct a movie with my friends and like yo
Del Toro and my Michael N directs Battle Star
Galactica in in these videos talking about those
things and then there's another part of it that
might be aspiring actors who might want to be part
of the project so they might want to walk on a
walk- on role or a speaking role or there might be
someone who wants to have a producer credit and so
they can put money in and get a producer credit so
so I was thinking about the different reasons that
someone might be interested and how they might
want to participate and those are different sort
of pie wedges of the whole of the whole pie
and so you have to be mindful of that as well
that's not one size fits all what are the first
few things that someone needs to do before they
crowdfund good question I guess investigation
of the market first it's like look around what's
going on what projects are being successful what's
happening why they are successful what other the
people is doing look around and see if there
is any project that similar to yours and and
what's the best way to you know when we started
with the c as I said we took all these projects
that inspired us and we took what was best out
of each one and put it together and try to build
our own model instead of just fitting in what
was what existed at the time so I think that's
important to you know research a little bit
and then I think it's important to be prepared
to be very very honest I think that's one of the
things that work better in our projects like don't
oversell sell what you have and and try to make
what you have really good but you know you need
to be sure that what you're doing is really good
and and and be honest what with what you're doing
be transparent I mean don't hide anything just
tell the you know when when our investor our Co
producer Russian co-producer drop out we could
have just said nothing because we were at risk
that 5,000 people that had given us money would
you know freak out to know that suddenly we had
130,000 years less and that the film was at risk
but instead of just you know saying nothing we we
were very public and was said guys we are on the
same team help us out and it worked and every time
something like that happened to us like you know
some things that went wrong or or some things that
we knew that people were maybe some people weren't
going to like we were like you know this is how it
is this is how we think and and it's the way it
goes and I think that's one of the most important
things to be prepared to be honest I don't know
if there's anything else that I can advise to be
prepared to how much should someone have invested
in social media beforehand that goes back to our
question sort of which comes first the chicken
or the egg and how do you stay honest in doing
that it seems like it's almost hard in some ways
to to build a a campaign if you know that you're
going to or excuse me it seems like it's almost
difficult to to build a social media Network a
little bit before a campaign if you know that it's
it's difficult and I I don't think it's something
you can pay for I mean you can pay for a campaign
or for social media whatever analyst or or company
and they can they can help you but you know at
some point for example every again every time
a client comes to us and says you know what we're
going to do this social media campaign and I want
a CO and I want you know all these tricks they
use to get traffic to the side we say you know
what we are not I mean we're not for you go to
somebody else because that's not natural I mean
it's not you you of course you can build numbers
but they're just numbers that's what we've been
you know fighting with brands for the last three
years because all they say is you only have 5,000
users 5,000 fans I say okay just take any page
that has 50,000 fans that will probably you know
it's just kind of easy to get numbers so check
that put a post and let's see how many comments
does it have and it usually have you know 15
people commenting 50 likes and we have 5,000
and you know we say something cool we have 200
comments and 500 likes so it's like that's our
numbers so again it's not about the amount it's
about the quality so you need to start from the
ground and start you know be like very little
at the beginning and I'm trying to connect with
people and trying to grow grow it bigger but you
need time for that that's you know the worst thing
of this is like it took us 3 years to build a
community and it's not even really big so you
need to be prepared to have time to build that you
can't do that in 30 days unless you're lucky you
know this happened to us it's like we launched the
project and then the week after one of the biggest
blogs in Spain talk about us because they like
the project and that was huge suddenly a thousand
people were coming to our site and and and all
of them were talking about us because they love
the project and you know that it it spreads but
you need to find something or be lucky enough to
have like a Kickarter something that you know
makes it big and from there well it depends on
how good you are on making it bigger but it's
difficult it's difficult to when something like
that I mean as I said you can't do something viral
it happens you can't prepare for it you can do it
you know have something that might be but again
try 100 different things and some of them might
go viral and and and give you the first Kickstart
well you mentioned it is work I mean it's like
having a full-time job and then some what's your
day like knowing that you launched the campaign
was it two days ago or yeah I think two or three
days ago yeah okay so do you have like a set like
a checklist of what you're doing every day to keep
that that drum yeah yeah I mean there's so much
work going on between the kickstarter campaign
and then the other fundraising that we're doing
for this project just with investors and whatnot
that don't have even have time to create a proper
checklist you know every day we every day we
come in it's just kind of a Mad scramble to
kind of do what needs to get done we know we need
to update people we know we know we need to kind
of check to see where we're at with Kickstarter
I'm a little obsessive about and I check maybe
every hour or so maybe sometimes more and so
you know the the obvious things are you know
making sure we're tweeting it out at least once
or twice a day and not doing it in an annoying
in your- face kind of way same with the Facebook
updates and you know Facebook and Twitter alone
there's multiple accounts that we're managing
between like the company's Twitter account and
the film's account so yeah there's a lot of kind
of just social media building Graphics that we'll
know that we know we'll need either that day or
down the road so yeah just kind of a roundabout
answer saying that we don't know what we're doing
half the time and just kind of doing as much as we
possibly can to get the word out every day yeah
what determined the length of time you're were
going to choose for the campaign I believe it's
what 31 days I think it's 31 days 31 days uhhuh
and also the amount 33,000 33,000 yeah the the we
came up with 33,000 as the goal in part because
we had to be realistic with what we could raise
given our Network given our our history with crown
funding like I just wanted to make sure we're
being realistic and not overshooting it because
as we all know Kickstarter is All or nothing and
we don't want to lose you know lose out so that
was one consideration the other consideration
was what will be enough to get the ball rolling
on the film what's enough to to develop the
project fully and what's enough to kind of
to start the the production process and 33,000
was kind of the magic number oh and the other
element of course is is in factoring in the cost
to produce the perks and the rewards and whatnot
for for backers and so yeah 33,000 33,000 was the
the magic number to get the ball rolling on the
project and and what we realistically thought we
could raise and so you decided to not go with like
a 52 day campaign you wanted it shorter I'm just
yeah I'm I can't I'm trying to remember why we
decided 31 days I mean we wanted to we wanted to
end the campaign on a Friday like in the evening
cuz everyone says to end it on a Friday which is
often Payday for people and you know you want to
give enough time to people to get home from their
jobs get on their email and exactly glass of wine
oh yeah glass of wine and get loose and you know
how do you get the wallet exactly yeah so I think
I think it ends on Friday like at 10:30 p.m.
or something like that oh that's great yeah
and did you I mean research other campaigns to
see what you saw worked and yeah we researched a
lot of campaigns we probably looked at about 100
different campaigns we watched all their videos
we looked at their rewards their perk structure
all the text on the actual Kickstarter page and
you know a lot of it came down to kind of what
felt good to us and we kind of went with our gut
as far as as as a viewer as an audience member as
a fan what do we want to read on these pages and
what kinds of perks would get us excited so along
the way we're just constantly telling ourselves
let's put ourselves in their shoes what do they
want to see what do they need to know what will
excite them and so that that helped a lot yeah and
what are the perks the perks for our Kickstarter
campaign include some of the more common things
like you know exclusive updates about the film
at the $2 level and then of course a copy of the
DVD a download of the film but then we came up
with some unique things like Instagram Polaroid
coasters because this film is going to be so
visually driven and hopefully cinematically kind
of beautiful we we wanted to kind of do something
having to do with photography so yeah one of the
perks is these cool little in these like Polaroid
cup coasters you know postcards and posters
a dinner with myself and the author of a book
called in pursuit of Silence which I'm sort of so
what has sort of influenced this this film and so
things like that yeah yeah that sounds really
cool that's creative the the dinner and with
the author I like that yeah thanks and another
consideration was because I experienced this with
our last crowdfunding campaign like it's got to
be rewards that are relatively simple for us to
put together one thing that was a constant Thorn
on our side with the last crowdfunding campaign
was this photo book this elusive photo book that
we promised backers and it seemed like a really
cool idea cuz we had a photographer on Set on
every shoot that we took in Haiti and so we had
these gorgeous photographs and we thought cool
you know let's do a photo book how hard could
it possibly be you know it was just like it was
just so it was expensive it took just so much
time to design it and it was just way more work
and money than than we anticipated and it became
a pretty big problem for us here in the office
just trying to get that done on time and ended
up being you know several months late but people
were happy when it finally came and then was that
Jess Jess Kaylor yeah K is our photographer and
she's brilliant I we we wanted to Showcase those
photos so badly that's kind of what drove us to
want to do this photo book but we didn't realize
how much work it would be W yeah beautiful photos
I remember seeing yeah I'll have to get you guys
a copy of the book before you guys leave yeah
Sherri what what's the question you get asked
most often I think everybody is really curious
about audience audience building and crowdfunding
I get a lot of questions about you know usually
after a campaign's already launched what which
sometimes is too late to be asking that question
often as well when you're launching going about
to launch your film and then you start asking
questions about the audience that's totally
backwards that all these questions really need
to be started in the very beginning of this you
know when you're making the film when you're
writing the script when you're thinking about
there should be in your mind who who am I writing
for who do I imagine watching this movie that I'm
writing I would think that would make it easier
a little bit in the process that you're you know
maybe putting in in jokes or you're being sure to
include a certain kind of information because you
know that's what your audience is going to want
to know if you don't have that idea when you're
writing it continues to be a problem throughout
into distribution because it's it remains vague
you're not sure who you're going after you're not
sure who's going to respond to this material and
it makes it that much harder because you're
putting on all your time and your effort and
your money into this without a clear idea of how
you're going to get anything out of it so you know
that's one of the big questions is audience and
the time to ask that is not we're in post and now
we're trying to figure it out or we're about to
raise money in crowdfunding and we need to figure
this out it's when you're developing the idea and
to start with I ask who are you you know what what
are you interested in what Drew you to this story
why do you feel compelled to tell it then where do
you hang out online where do you hang out offline
what do you read who do you listen to all those
aspects to starting with with you makes it lots
easier because you know yourself you know that's
not hard to to identify it's when they start with
these demographics 18 to 35 women you know that's
a huge huge desperate group they don't all love
the same things so thinking more along the lines
of interest and psychology and what emotionally
moves it really takes you then out of an age group
you're really targeting then an interest group
a psychology that you want to find and it's much
easier to find those people than when you're just
targeting a blank Age and and once you do once you
have identified your audience and you're sort of
ready to take that next step what are those next
steps you know where do you go from there well
I have S of changed my thoughts about when you
should start this process of audience engagement
one I think that artists should be doing that all
the time so in that way you are creating your own
identity in marketing speak it would be brand I
find filmmakers don't like to use that word but
I mean in marketing that is what it is a brand
is your identity your personality so you should be
sharing that personality all the time when you're
online professionally I don't mean what are you
having for breakfast where you went on vacation
with your family you know deep dark secrets
about yourself I don't mean to to to make all
your private thoughts known and your privacy given
up but from a professional standpoint what drives
you what motivates you and and start you can start
today you know with sharing that of figuring of
of pulling people toward you who are of that same
mindset who are compelled by the same thing you're
compelled with a great book that I read over was
called start with Y it's by Simon cynic and he
says people don't buy what you do they buy why
you do it so you should always be showing people
your why you know you should always start from
thinking how does this show why I do what I do
and those same people who are compelled to do to
think that way or do those things or are motivated
by the same things that you are get drawn to you
now if you're a negative person and I've seen
this happen a lot online where people are very
cutting and they cut other people down and they
always have really negative things to say and then
they get surprised when negativity starts coming
back at them you know on their sites in their
comments on their blogs on their Facebook page
lots of negative comments it's what what you're
putting out in the world is what is coming back
into you what's attracted to you so if you don't
want that then don't be that don't show that of
yourself online but so that's what you start to
begin with now if you have a project during the
time when you're in production when you're writing
and you're in production you're you're stockpiling
you're collecting you're looking for all the
assets that you're going to be able to use or
that you can use to create more material for later
but hold off on the online engagement opening up
your social channels till you're about six months
from your Premiere because in six months you can
keep the motivation up you can keep the momentum
you can release new things and six months is not
a terrible burden and the audience can stay with
you for that long if you're 2 years or 3 years
to making a film you're not going to be able to
keep up that Project Specific content release
for very long it's just it will be too draining
for you you'll run out of ideas and the audience
will get bored you know they they when is this
thing happening when is this thing coming out
they kind of do expect that when they hear about
it it's soon going to be released and they'll be
able to see it so they can wait about 6 months
or about four months but they can't wait for
indefinite period of time so when you're thinking
about project wise for a long time you're going
to be collecting and thinking about how you're
going to release and then when you get into post
and when you see okay we're about 6 months from
when it doesn't have to be a firm date you know
you don't have to know if you're doing it from a
festival you won't know if you're going to get in
but but you know around October or around January
it'll be ready and we will be looking to have the
premiere then get started then start showing your
your project off and getting interest and getting
people then you're maintaining your pages and
you're cultivating an audience for the project
how many days into the campaign are we 54 right
now3 5 days in or something like that 5 days in
and we've got 54 days left uh it's nerve-wracking
yeah it is it's very nerve-wracking but we're
going to work as hard as we can to you know
reach the public with this project as best as
we can we're going to Tweet it until my fingers
fall off I'm going to email it and send it out
email I haven't slept in B we haven't slept we
just been online there all night just sending
it to people trying to reach reach reach a lot
of people out there so they can try to help us
support this project yeah we're getting very good
responses a lot of people really like the project
and uh they're really like the videos and they
they're inspired by it too the thing is though
I I I'm learning though people are they gravitate
to the child abduction human trafficking in this
country too so they're like I didn't know that and
I have a supplementary video that gives a lot of
statistics about those subjects and when people
see that I get I'm getting a lot of emails and
uh tweets back about I didn't know that it was
really happening here and then that just gives
me more and more fuel and lets me know that this
you know film needs to be made so that people can
be more aware of it is it anybody resonating with
the characters trying to change the course that
they were once on and make a new life or is that
not totally revealed not totally revealed that's
the to me I think that's more the intricacies of
the story and for me to sum it up the the real
cause for me though it's a great story but the
real cause for me is the child abduction human
trafficking you know in the country I I hope
people are really aware of that and and and
and you know become aware that that is something
that's happening here and you know and you know I
hope that inspires people to really you get behind
the cause but the kickstar has been going really
good we've got a long way to go but you know we're
still going to keep pushing it and getting it out
there and we we hope people you know help us get
this film made and so what are the the ground
rules you have like do you have a daily checklist
of what you do or just you just know everyday's go
hit the ground run it's just me and him so it's
hard some some people some people have like a
team of like 20 people before the kick start just
me and him so I got the the the morning routine
I go online and he also he also he also does the
same thing so we do it in the morning and at night
so we barely sleep we we on it all the time we
take like breaks here and there cuz sometime you
get discouraged wow I just send it like a thousand
emails I don't it's still not moving you know what
I mean and then oh yeah somebody plays I'm okay
we're good let's keep going let's keep going it
doesn't take much to keep us going you know all
I need is a good tweet you retweet me I'm still
going I'm not going to quit if you retweet me I'll
take the little things for now but yeah we work in
shifts and you know it's we take our breaks you
know you CU you put in hours doing that you get
kind of loopy looking at the screen so much so you
know take a break and you know get a cup of coffee
go at it again you know in the end is you know
it's just try to reach as many people you know
as we can I think we have too we got a lot of
people like maybe like that that like like the
page or they just send us a message oh we like we
like the project but they don't they don't pledge
but we get a lot of them that that like the
project and stuff like that so we we reaching
some of them we doing we're doing good so far the
time frame to we on 5 days so we're doing good so
far so what are some of the highs and some of the
lows what what what things are are the ones where
you go and then takes you back up again besides
the tweets okay it just film making in general
or the kickstarter promotion for the Kickstarer
keep ourselves going we keep ourselves going so
yeah it's literally like and luckily it's we're
never at a point where we're both down so it's
always he'll call me 4 in the morning yo you good
and I'll call him again oh you good we call him
we call each other every like 2 three hours we
call each other I I would I would definitely say
the low for me is if you get back somebody like uh
you know you you you get some negatives every once
in a while like oh you know I don't know you so
don't send me tweets and stuff like that you get
you get stuff like that but then you know you hit
a couple people later and somebody retweets me and
I'm say hey thank you and that's enough for me
to keep going because not everybody shares the
same mentality and you know I just feed off of
that you know you're going to have negativity
and things like that but you you have to again
here comes the thick skin you just let it roll
off and you keep on going you know so you're
your own support system to you yeah absolutely
absolutely and it works cuz we're both stubborn
so both extremely stubborn we won't quit we won't
quit we're going to find some way to get through
it you know what I mean like my mom said somebody
blocks you try to break the door go through
it so that's how we that's how we doing yeah
yeah you know I find it very interesting that that
you two said that you knew this $28,000 goal was
kind of like wow this was at the high end of the
spectrum you know and and you said that you too
kind of like going after the impossible and sort
of like really pushing it Can can we talk about
setting setting that particular number goal cuz
I I think that's that's often one of the things
that everyone sort of struggles with it's like
okay I think I want to make this project and I
think I'm going to want to try to try crowdfunding
and setting that goal can be so tricky because you
just don't know you don't you don't know how to
size it up so can you talk about the $20,000 goal
and yeah so I think our original plan was to do
a second season of our web series and when we ran
the numbers for that we were going to originally
run a crowdfunding campaign for that we were going
to set that at maybe 10 to 12 and you know when
looking at the numbers of what what we expected
and hope to get where where we could reach
we thought we thought that was doable then we
decided to to change it up do it as a feature and
so nothing as far as our resources change but but
the budget change and so we we set it at a at the
minimum point that we could do production of the
future so that's how that's how we came to that
number so that doesn't necessarily even cover all
of prod but it covers enough that we could still
find a way to get production production route get
it in the can so that's how we came up with that
number and I think you know like he said you know
our original thought was okay maybe 10,000 for for
the the second season of the web series and you
know when we did the first one we didn't have any
budget at all I mean we had a camera and a lot of
interested people and a lot of drive and and you
know that's about it and you know when we looked
at our final product we were we were proud of
the experience and that we had done it and we
had spent so many countless hours doing it but
you know getting to do it a second time I mean
that's a really unique opportunity to be able to
work with the same people and kind of see them
grow having seen them grow over the year and like
what else they're bringing to the table and even
myself like I'm I'm kind of new at this you know
cuz he he's always been doing this but it's not
until recently that you know his goals became my
goals as well and so you know I I I am I had a lot
more to bring with myself as well so you know we
talked about a lower number but it's like that's
not we we didn't want to make the same mistake as
the first time you know we're we're just having
a very ambitious project where you can't get it
reasonably shot and it's not what it looks like
or it's not what you want it to look like and
then so I think you know we had to like that
was actually the minimum number that we would need
and you know we could supplement the rest with you
know our own income or you know take a loan here
and there or whatever but you know we we can make
up that small difference that we needed to get to
our to our full budget but but any lower than that
you know if we had set at 25 or if we had set
it at 10 I mean we're still looking at you know
trying to raise another 1015 and and you know who
knows where that would have put us in the end and
and our goal with this film was to to make a good
film like she said with the first season of the
web series you know we had no budget we we had no
not a lot of production value and we didn't want
to make another we didn't want to make another
project that was good given the resources we just
wanted to make one that was good period not like
well that was good considering what you didn't
have or that was good considering this or that
or that just you know something that was good so
you're preparing to launch a crowdfunding campaign
yes in February March to to give us a nice little
production budget for season 2 of laps so what's
some of your prep work that you're doing it's
going to going to be well the biggest thing is
like trying to figure out what are these rewards
you know that's such a big thing because that's
that's the thing that's enticing people to donate
you know what what are they getting out of it and
I'm actually I'm I'm gearing I'm I'm compiling
a list but I don't have like a set list yet of
things some of them are like we did a commentary
for season one that I never released so and
it's with it's honestly so long ago that I don't
remember doing this remember me art or me you me
and Art Hall who is not here right now sitting
next to me manifestation I'm actually rhe in a
mask I would have gotten away with it too yeah all
right so yeah we all sat around we all sat around
we Matt Lewis was there where where we record this
at R's apartment you're right was there some wine
involved what probably chance I guarantee actually
there were usually whenever also whenever I do
commentary that's usually how it go you always
hear a crack of a beer can or of a Miller time
it's Miller time she knows me yeah so we so we did
that and I'd like to put that out as like a one
of the rewards cuz it's really funny it's probably
I'm got to guess maybe it's just funny to us but
no I'm just kidding no t-shirts not doing t-shirt
I would like to do doing t-shirts yeah because
the show the show is such a workout you know like
going to the track kind of thing it'd be cool to
have like a tank top or something you know not you
know fanny pack fanny pack right to keep the phone
and the cigarettes yeah exactly all the things you
need when you work out you need the wide one for
the cigars you know right exactly like a little
hip humidor yeah that's a good idea though it's
like well maybe flask maybe we could have DVDs of
the first season yeah you know all bonus featur
the audition t tapes I think is interesting he
doesn't like that no one likes audition tapes okay
all right I don't no actors like well maybe some
actors like their own audition tapes and if they
do I'm a little leery about a little leery about
that so yeah I'm I'm getting that stuff together
and then in a couple weeks we're we're going to
shoot the like the the pitch video oh great okay
and are you having everybody involved and yeah
you'll narrate it or I'll probably sort of like
the video Journal I'll intro it but we'll shoot
it back at the track and I'd like to have all the
roles cast by then so that we can have the entire
cast there and just be like you know this is what
we're this is our team of actors and talent that
are going to bring season two to life kind
of thing and then ask for money are you doing
research on what campaign videos sort of strike a
court in you yeah like did you have any examples
of I know II was a great campaign video II J Town
yeah she did a great yeah and there was also well
I I do like um God what's that guy that we were
just talking about the feature film that he's
been working on for years oh oh the guy from No No
Film School oh c yeah cou did such an amazing job
with this video absolutely yeah I mean the tricks
that he used in that video was really cool I don't
know what I'm going to pull that but you know he
had a really good pitch and that's what this is
going to come down to is do you have a compelling
pitch and yeah I'm looking at other campaigns and
it's not like I'm using just one for like an
example I'm looking at several and then like
taking piece by piece and making notes kind of
thing so I wish I had more examples but it's more
just as I go I'm like oh that's pretty cool that's
pretty cool and I tuck it away and and then how
have you determined how much you're going to ask
for one thing we've seen recently is that people
are really going for these high amounts right and
it it's been it's been harder these days to get
them I think people are the honeymoon period is
kind of over for crowdfunding I think it's it's
a little tougher now right and there's also a
huge debate between Indiegogo and Kickstarter M
which I'm still debating okay yeah but I'm going
to I'm going to keep it low you know I know that
I can fall back back on some you know of my own
personal money but also some friends here in La
that have camera equipment that I would like to
you know they've already said yeah you can go and
use it so I'm keeping the budget low it's mostly
for locations because it's such a bigger story you
know yeah yeah the locations are that's going to
be a big piece of it I want to be able to have the
money for food and whatever you know lighting is
a big thing too so Arts place that's true we well
if there's a way to fake it into a two bedroom
apartment absolutely I'm I'm open to it I've I
have I've did various sure various Apartments I've
lived in I've always allowed people to film it and
like I I'm like oh sure of course halfway through
I'm like damn it why did I say yes to this cuz
you know it's a little wurling dervish comes into
your apartment everything just gets all over but
of course no we'll make it work you know but yeah
the world is much bigger but I think it's going to
strongly benefit us so yeah so I'm not going to
shoot for the I'm going for $100,000 budget I'm
going for like a 3500 and yeah like pretty modest
I mean it's really modest for what I made season
one on like 20 bucks maybe plus CR Services yeah
yeah like however much bottles of water and donuts
yeah Taco about tacos for everybody Taco about
tacos and lots of starches and carbs which is
perfect for somebody that's trying to lose weight
yeah thank you and then you're not planning on
going on any vacations or anything during during
the campaign we talked about earlier no not at
all no weddings or anything no I'm just going to I
mean I'm going to Vegas for a couple days in April
but that's pretty much it so yeah you can't go
toas okay I guess I'm not going toas anym you can
tweet from tweet from Vegas I will send a picture
of me at Caesar Circus Circus I think has good
Wi-Fi well you have the LTE network that's true
we do right we have plans so what else have you
noticed from crowdfunding campaigns that you like
what what are the some of the things that you've
seen that have really worked and then some that
haven't the over budg is I feel like a big one but
not having a good pitch video to me I feel like is
the ones I've seen I'm like I would never donate
to that cu the video wasn't good whether it was a
production value or just the pitch wasn't good I
just didn't feel like it was a compelling enough
story or you know that kind of stuff so I really
want to make sure I'm good with that do you think
people view that as okay if the pitch video is bad
then what's the actual production going to look
like is this a representation of their work well
I mean that's the way I take it I don't feel that
just a pitch video is enough I feel that people
are buying not just a reward like a DVD or t-shirt
or chance for a sign script or something they're
they're trying to become a part of a process that
they normally wouldn't be so invite them along
on that Journey like you know show them where
you're coming from where you want to go like the
good things the bad things that happened so keep
them in the loop and that's what I've seen on the
successful ones I've only followed one or two I'm
very loose I hardly ever looked but I know one of
them was kind of an easy sell I forgot the guy's
name but he was one of these video game developers
in the 90s who did a lot of point-and-click
Adventures like day the tacal and stuff like
that and he wanted to make a throwback point
and click game for all the people who reminisce
like me and all those other people and he's said
$100,000 what I need to fully design an engineer
and develop this this program and he would make
videos if not weekly than daily to talk about
progress and all the artwork and everything he
made three or $400,000 because people were so on
board with you know that part of it is again the
subject matter of you know you're you're playing
on the Nostalgia of the game you know culture from
that era but he took you on a ride and showed you
how did things work and that I think is really
the big thing that's why it's you need a marketing
team or someone full-time because takes a lot to
consistently update and send messages and video
and then edit and all that stuff so that's what
I think is really the big indicator or big thing
to help and for me the video journals is is is
trying to do that mhm and do you think you'll do
a shorter campaign 30 days or longer I'm I'm right
now I'm on 30 yeah what what makes you like that
date that 30-day t I don't know it's a good number
you it's just a month and you try it out if it the
other thing too is I know that there's the the
chance of failure you don't make it in 30 days
you know so then we need to to do another campaign
or that's true you have a fall back instead of
putting it all in 160 day campaign I guess yeah
yeah because I'm I'm not doing this campaign to
be like I'm I'm GNA you know please donate and
we might shoot in a year it's like I'm doing
this campaign please donate we're shooting in May
you know we're ready to go well you're not going
to be able to sleep if it's not exactly true I I
mean yeah you like to do things quite a while and
that's great I I like to have things ready like I
didn't start I didn't start try to I I didn't try
to cast lap season one without the script being
in a good place you know I feel like you need to
have confidence in in you know someone's going
to come onto your team you got to have a basis
you know you got to have that that thing is that's
going to motivate people to be like no I want to
work on that and if and that requires me to have
my stuff in line have it in check and ready you
know Michael how would you compare and contrast
Kickstarter to Indiegogo and
would you give the edge to
Indiegogo they're very different now Kickstarter
and Indiegogo I mean when they first started it
was kind of like hey there's this new platform
for funny movies and what not I think through
time they've kind of separated a lot Kickstarter
obviously is probably a little more mainstream I
just from people I know talking to them they they
they feel a little more comfortable not So Much
Anymore with Kickstarter just because it's known
a little more on the press and all that I honestly
I I don't know their goals or where they're going
but I feel like they're really separating and kick
and Indiegogo is kind of the the place where
you go where you're you know the Indie spirit
I should say is alive in Indiegogo abut and it's
and socially too they do a lot of social campaigns
that that work well Kickstarter seems much more
now like I say it's pre-sales now they don't
really I don't know they don't do so much pre-sell
in movies anymore but it's kind of it's kind of
going I know the kickstarter people probably don't
like that because they' sent messages and all that
like you you know we're a donation based site
but I think the because because of kickstarter's
mainstream success they've attracted you know
certain compan they attracted like the video games
industrial design type companies which aren't
they're so already fully funded they're not like
a little movie where it's like hey we're going
to go shoot this little movie and hopefully it'll
turn out good and it's just us and we're kind of
artists not that video game people aren't artists
by any means but you know it's it's it's in their
business plan almost in a way as where indigogo
still is kind of independent and and you know we
need your money to make this movie whereas the
other things are kind of we oh yeah we just want
to cut off some of our losses before we release I
video game or whatnot so but they both have good
and valid points I would probably our docs are a
little more mainstream so I think Kickstarter is
a little better way to go for that but then the
movies we do are so for such a limited audience
that it's like yeah you know and it's it's the
movies such as the one we're doing now is it's
all people just doing the movie because they want
to do the movie you know there's no other real
goal like you know all the actors kind of really
like the concept and they want to do the movie
because of the concept over any kind of success
they see in the future well who's the audience
for love touch hate what do you envision it's
such a tough answer to say who the audience for
the movie is because it's a very I think on the
on the the actual movie is very I think audience
friendly it's a it's a Bittersweet comedy there's
elements of Comedy it's a fatherson story which
we don't really talk about in the campaign because
it's just too much to put in the little video the
initial conceits of the movie could be mainstream
but it could be very very Indie and my take on
it is a very very Indie take because I'm just I'm
exploring something and it's not the not the the
way the Hollywood movie would probably be in terms
of structure so it's a kind of a tough thing to
say I think you know the audience is pretty pretty
small but the people who actually show up to watch
the movie would probably like it a lot that makes
sense well I think number one the most
important thing is to start from a place
of passion I think I could probably I would not
have had a successful Kickstarter campaign we
wouldn't have had a successful Kickstarter
campaign if we weren't truly 100% passionate
about the film because your passion I think
will come through in any type of promotion
you do video to me seems like the biggest
no-brainer of all time for filmmakers but
a lot you know a lot of filmmakers
for whatever reason either they're
gunshy31 or you know what all the all the typical
you know ways that people like to think of you
know crazy filmmakers the truth is if you care
enough about your project to you know sweat Blood
and Tears to get it done you should care enough to
tell people why and I think that if you start from
a place of honesty and passion in however you're
communicating all you'll already be ahead of the
pack I think the mistake that a lot I see a lot
of Indie filmmakers make when they start making
some sort of tape is that they they'll try to
maybe like ape or copy a different campaign
that was successful but that may be completely
inappropriate for what it is they're doing and
more often than not you watch a filmmaker and you
go who cares you know I you know I I don't care I
bet you a lot of filmmakers when they watch that
own tape that probably don't it probably doesn't
move them but I think if you again if you step
from a place of honesty and and you you create
something that's as real as the movie you made in
the first place something as personal and cool and
quirky and interesting as your own work people are
going to respond and I mean listen I'm a big sap
but I when I watch our Kickstarter video I still
tear up and you know yes part of it is because
I have to admit that I look that Goofy on camera
but part of it is because I I really I really do
it the journey meant so much to us that it was
impossible not to be passionate when we talked
about it so I think my first tip would be start
from a place of honesty and passion what's your
second tip I'm getting it in order I I I know what
it is I know what my second tip is but go ahead I
thought you might want want to expand expand on
the passion no I absolutely agree we um we're
working with some filmmakers now who are doing a
documentary called Journey Through Fire and they
actually came and and one of the video things that
they're doing which I thought was really nice is
they're talking to different filmmakers and having
them almost pitched the film where you know what I
mean what is it that inspired them about about the
film or what is it that inspires them about the
project which I think again to the passion that
it's not just the filmmaker's passion but the show
that the film has inspired a passionate response
in others I think definitely helps in terms of
having you know testimonials you know within the
pitch video which is not something we did but I
saw them doing it just recently they're working
did different kinds of testimonials right but you
know for them it really I mean they're still still
in the in the in the editing process they don't
have their film finished yet you know we saw rough
cuts and little bits and pieces and you know found
out about the stories and all of that but you
know again it's speaking to the passion it's just
what's your passion if you know if I'm an audience
member and you know you're the filmmaker of course
you're passionate about your project but to see
somebody else get passionate about your project
who's not necessarily connected to it in any way
that's intriguing and then I go oh you know what
what is in your project that's s their passion
then that may also then spark mine and I think
one one idea that you're hitting on there that I
do think is important if you're lucky enough to
have it is social proof you know basically proof
that there is a love of your project outside your
own love you know because of course you love it
you wouldn't have you know spent all your money
and all your time making it we were so lucky to
that when we played our initial festivals that we
were not only winning but we were getting standing
ovations and and we we brought cameras with with
us to the screenings in hopes of gathering some
type of audience reaction it far exceeded our
expectations but being able to show people
our film is receiving One Standing Ovation
after another and people in the lobby are unable
to contain themselves and they're and they're
they're crying and talking about the film and this
is what real people are saying about the movie I
think lent a lot of credibility and it also made
people feel good about supporting the film whether
it was donating or watching or deciding to buy a
ticket it's like well there's other people in the
world being moved by this movie that only say not
only says to me that it's good it also says to me
this is something I want to be a part of you know
am I missing out by not seeing this film is is it
you know would my life you know maybe be touched
like that person's life was touched if I took the
time to go see it or or not not all movies are
need to be touching it could be a comedy you know
am I going to have that much fun at the movies
you know is is it worth me going to escape for a
few hours so I do think that if you can hint
at Social proof in any kind of pitch you do
for I for anything just proving that that there's
there's a more Universal you know attractiveness
to your project I do think that will help the next
point that I think is is is really important and I
think this speaks to again it doesn't matter if
you're making a movie if you're selling widgets
you know if you're you're trying to get book to
give speeches whatever I think you have to know
your audience you know it's really important
to know that audience and to speak to them and
and I don't that that necessarily mean a lot of
people will go oh well who's your audience and
then they'll automatically start breaking it down
into demographics I don't think that necessarily
works as well for independent filmmakers I mean
yes it's important to know in general you know
this movie is going to appeal to men more than
women or or vice versa but a lot of times Indie
filmmakers fall into this weird in between place
because we're making something that's different
and it doesn't necessarily fit one specific mold
so I think you want to figure out how to appeal to
certain pieces of everybody I mean I think we all
have you know in the case of dying to do Letterman
I think we all have an underdog Spirit no matter
who you are no matter if you're a man or woman no
matter what age you are all of us at some point in
our lives have been the underdog or rooted for an
underdog and that was something we worked really
hard to tap into when we you know when we reached
out and it was not only reflected in our video
which very clearly said no one wanted us to make
this movie which was true people said it you know
it was a horrible idea to shoot the film people
thought we were crazy to invest our money in it I
mean we we were underdogs Steve's story is a major
Underdog Story So by saying to people you know
look we're underdogs be part of our Underdog Story
I think that help them relate to the movie I think
if you can find something that's Universal in your
film and be and think of that as your demographic
what's my demographic it's underdogs we all have a
little piece of the underdog you know so in a way
it makes it easier to focus your message like like
you're tapping into that Essence as opposed
to I'm just going for the you know 18 to 39y
old male which probably if you're an independent
filmmaker you probably don't fit a category quite
so sharply unless you set out to make a commercial
film which is a whole different business plan alog
together so one we applaud what's that oh I
I listen I I I I think yes well that's that's
a whole side note I think unfortunately I think
a lot of independent filmmakers get lumped into
well you can only make one kind of movie which
is not true an independent filmmaker is a person
that goes and makes a movie with their own money
because no one else will pay for it you know I
think that if someone went out and they did their
independent version of Armageddon God bless him
I'd support him 100% I do think there's a bias
against you know young aspiring filmmakers who
tend to make stuff that appeals to the masses
as opposed to Niche audiences so for the record
I completely support anybody and applaud anybody
who who has the gumption The Finisher movie and
if your movie happens to be Armageddon or a horror
movie or a comedy and it doesn't fit your typical
you know Festival Festival model it's I I don't
think people should care I think you should be
applauded for finishing your film in the first
place so that's that's a whole rant for another
day do you think that crowdfunding
is hurting or even ruining social
media wow that's a really really hard question
explain it to me a little bit more I mean what do
you mean well it seems like you know it's great
to follow people it's great to be supportive
of what they're doing but when you feel that
they've friended you or they've followed you
and they're singing your praises and then a week
later they let you know about their crowdfunding
campaign it almost feels as if social media has
now become more about marketing instead of being
social okay yes the answer is yes and let me give
you an example and I think this is a huge mistake
from people making projects you know you can't
push it you I mean it's stupid to ask people for
money we have never done that in 3 years actually
our friends you know it's like first thing you do
when you make a crowfunding campaign is just
harass your friends like hey vote me give me
money share this what I mean even with my friends
I tell them it's like dude why let me Discover it
let me I mean and I'm not going to like it because
it's you I'm going to like it because I like it
so let me Discover it let me let me just you know
give me the opportunity to watch it but don't ask
me to vote you or to give you money because you
are you and that's a huge mistake that can kill a
project so you know we we never push it that way
we just put the project online and it was funny
because our friends you know it took like two
years for them to give us money you know two years
when we had been a success in Spain we've been
in in every media and everything they decided to
put money and you know it was am amazing because
at that point I felt that that the project was a
success you know when even my friends that you
were tired of listening listening me talk about
the project they decided to get in so I think it's
important not to push it and and you know have a
different idea of what social is and and what Crow
funding is like make friends and that's okay and
they're going to help you probably to you know
to talk about the project but if you're asking
them for money do in a different platform or do
it or don't do it at all I mean let the other
people talk about you that's much more powerful
somebody talks about you so you have how many
days left in the campaign 13 13 13 okay yeah
I think that's why I just tweeted I bet oh I
was 14 but oh it ends at like 3 in the morning or
something right which it might as well be 13 yeah
so you're you're coming down the home stretch what
are some of the mistakes that you've made and then
what are some of the things that worked that you
know you'll continue if you ever go back again
I've been doing a lot of of reading of people's
recommendations and a lot of people have said that
you should email your social friends before you
start the campaign and ask them to help you and
I think that's a really good idea and something we
didn't do right and like we said before not having
a lot of stuff prepared beforehand just because
of the time crunch that we are under so we would
have loved to have had some video updates sort
of pre shot and edited and ready to go so that
we could just every Monday we do like a video
from a different person or whatever but so that
that would be something next time going into it
if we have more time right okay and do you find
that a lot of people get back to you if you send
emails no they don't it's really surprising that
no one gets back to you so I don't know what that
is interesting okay do or like oh friends I I mean
talking like newspapers trying to get newspaper
ads you know you give people ideas do you want
you could you could do an article about this you
could do an article about that crowdfunding local
girl horror movie small movie 50 other things and
well there's a lot of news in chica so they don't
need your ideas for stories but we've we've gone
we've gone inside and and found someone who knows
someone so that we're trying that we're trying
that out for SL oh okay yeah I think I think
having making contacts with with media Outlets
beforehand really would have been helpful to try
to sort of get some media exposure lined up before
the campaign right and it's how many days total we
chose 30 30 okay are you happy with that amount
or do you wish you'd gone I believe Kickstarter
when they say longer isn't better so and it's so
exhausting and such a huge process I mean that
60-day campaign looks like a nightmare to me so
I couldn't imag imagine yeah that's a long time
because it is a job and there's so much momentum
that you build I mean we're right in the middle
right now and we're definitely seeing our schlump
in the middle that all Kickstarter campaigns have
you have a big in the beginning you have a a big
exciting shoot up and then again at the end you
have another one so it's like a bell curve how
would you change the perks of Kickstarter well
one of the worst things that Kickstarter per has
and it's not the model that they built but how
people use it is that you know if you pay 10 to
15 or maybe $20 for a DVD on a store why are you
paying 30 for one in Kickstarter because what
because it's an indie project because it's you
know what's up with that why the minimum amount
just to appear in the credits it's $10 or $5 for a
thank you it's like dude I mean look at the market
pre-sale if you want but why people I mean why are
you making people pay more for and you know if if
you're if your target audience for the kickstarter
campaign or people that is related to cool and new
things that's all right because you know it's like
an added value they're going to they're not going
to you know they're going to spend it but for
normal people if you want to reach like a broad
audience yes pre-sale as as you were in the market
competing to other people and other DVDs and other
films and at the same time perks you know they
give you a lot of work a lot of work and if that's
the only way to find your film you're not going
to find your film you know for the C from from
Strictly crowdfunding like selling merchandise we
rise like $50,000 half of that went to pay for the
stock of the things you know all the t-shirts and
the The Mailing and everything else and the other
half would have gone to pay the guys that were
making packages for 5,000 people for 2 years so in
the end there's no money for the film you know we
got the real money from investment from from crowd
investment you know people found in the internet
that were you know buying a percentage of the film
but the rest was just promotion which is great if
you take it that way it's like okay let's promote
the film let's going to sell t-shirt because you
know that's going to be people wearing a message
of the film and telling about it but to get real
money out of that is difficult John how often
would you say that a filmmaker reaches out to
you with let's say 5 days left in a crowdfunding
campaign and you want to help them so you mean in
terms of reach us out in in what way you know
like help my campaign pretty much I get that
once a week and I ignore it you know it's like I
don't know if someone's just saying I ignore and
you know for better anyone who just says oh John
help me with my crowdfunding campaign you know to
me it's like I don't have a relationship with you
you know you're reaching out to me when you just
want money or you want my help getting you money
it's like well you haven't learned anything from
any lesson that I've ever taught you know it's
like why what is the point what is the why would
I engage with you at that point you know if you
want to engage with me in advance of that in any
way shape or form even to ask me a question on
Twitter and seek my advice on something or make
a joke or somehow involve me as a person great
and then you have a crowdfund campaign and you
say hey John could you do this because we have a
relationship sure but I don't even keep track of
how many people say oh promote my this that or the
other thing and I don't have a relationship with
them and I ignore it and I feel perfectly fine
ignoring it because that person hasn't made the
effort to have a relationship with me it's pretty
easy to have a relationship with me I have to say
you know I'm pretty busy and sometimes it takes
me some days to get back to people and stuff
and you know but generally it's rare that I don't
within a couple of weeks respond to everything so
you know with that being said if you haven't tried
then you're not really you know you're not trying
hard enough so is that are those things that you
would love to tell them but either don't have the
time or though yeah I don't even bother at that
point it's like you know it's like it's just it's
not my job to tell people that I'm not engaging
with them when they're asking me to help them
make money when they haven't engaged me beforehand
and because I say that all the time to people so
you obviously haven't read my book and so if you
haven't read my book then why are you asking me
to help you so when my book is so cheap and easily
available you know and even and generally if you
ask me for a free copy generally I'll give you a
free copy so with that being said it's interesting
that you know people need to remember that you
know that we're in an exchange based economy
or referral based economy and that you know if
you want to someone to do something with you you
have to provide them value on some level you know
and I'm not saying that to be selfish or you know
you know demanding or anything like that but you
have to start practicing those muscles or exercise
those muscles in order to be successful and the
other thing is if you're coming to me for help in
the last 5 days of your crowdfund campaign chances
are you're too late because and this is the thing
about crowdfund campaigns that people don't
understand the way you structure your campaign
is how you're will largely determine how you're s
whether you're successful or not and that goes in
terms of how much you ask for what your rewards
are what your positioning is what your call
to action is all of that which which is in the
structuring of the campaign will help determine
whether you're successful or not so and that's
why 5 days before the end of the campaign is most
likely too late for any kind of help that I can
provide you know or I would want to provide you
know Nicholas are you able to tell people what
the keys are to crowdfunding or do you feel that
I know we talked earlier and you said really you
can't tell people how to do it you just know how
to do it yourself yes you know it's like I think
it's very personal and the the key for our project
you know I can talk about what I think we did
right and and I know we did a lot of things
that were wrong and the good thing about doing
a threeyear campaign not a 30-day or a 90-day
campaign is that you can try many different
things and that's what we did you know and
many of them were huge failur and and many of
them were successes what I think is I mean the
reason I think I you know it's very difficult to
advise on how to make a crowdfunding campaign is
because I don't think people in something that
is related to film or art you know if you're
crowdfunding I don't know something physical
that you're are selling is like you're selling
a product but if you're talking about something
Arty I think people gives you money not because
the project but because of you something very
personal you know it's like I always say we've
we've done two films one of them is the cosm which
is you know science fiction film whatever and the
other thing is the story of three guys you know
three students willing to make a film and how
we told that story over 3 years with videos and
the blog and you know everything we we we spoke
about is what made people engage with us and and
be willing to give us money and if the project
have been about anything else it would have been
the same that's my guess I'm not sure I might be
wrong maybe everyone loves space on the Space Race
but you know it's kind of I think it wasn't about
especially the film but the way we talk about it
so I guess it's it it's you know the success of R
will depend on on the person behind and and how
good he's able to express himself and to pitch
in a way pitch the pr so people are investing in
you not sort of filmed not your I guess some you
know some of them invested in the film itself
and actually there is people that doesn't even
know who's behind you know it happened to us it's
like okay the COS I know the COS that project I
don't who you are oh okay I'm the director hello
but you know I think that comes after it's like
the first people that is going to start talking
about you it's going to do it because they they
like what you're telling them or the way you're
telling them that I don't know I might be wrong
it's I think it's really difficult and there's
been like now everyone is doing crowdfunding
all the time with with a thousand projects and
not many of them are are being s a success which
is sad but I think we are in the beginning of
something you know it's like something's going
to grow and and needs to adapt you know I think we
are living a pretty pretty exciting time and that
we have given a huge opportunity as filmmakers
to not only because we have a lot of things that
we we didn't have like 15 years ago that allow
us us to make films which is much cheaper and
easier and and all that but because we are in
a in a really in a change of model and and and
a change of of of how the industry works you know
at that point where where everything changes which
is what happened you know when the sound came to
film or when the new Hollywood and manle B arriv
that they were you know changing everything how
how it worked and and we're at that point now I
mean we are we are at one of those points that
where we are going to define the next 20 or 30
years of film I think it's pretty exciting to be
there so related to crowdfunding or creative Comm
or new distribution models or trans media I think
you know we need to to be mistaken we need to just
try things and and for them to go wrong we need
to have a thousand failures in in crowdfunding
to get one success and see and say okay that was
the way way to go or or you know it's it's like
when when when you have a success in in anything
you know you have a film about magicians and then
you have 10 films about magicians so because you
know it's a bus and probably the only success is
going to be the first one because it was the first
one and that's so we need to you know keep doing
things and and keep building and discover what's
coming next so I first discovered your project
for tiny a story about living small while I was
on Kickstarter and tell us about how you began
the campaign I know you it was December 2011
or so when you started it or little B I think
we started it sort of late October and then ended
December 15th was our last day okay so what types
of things were you doing ahead of time to plan it
because you've done a beautiful job at at getting
awareness out about it I mean so many people just
they make a video they put it on Kickstarter and
then they are very passive about it and it seems
like you were both very proactive about about it
what were your strategies either ahead of time or
while the campaign was in motion well let right
this because she's The Mastermind the architect
of the of the kickstarter campaign I mean I think
one of the really lucky things about our project
is that we had sort of the tiny house Community
there you know ready to kind of help us get the
word out and in the tiny house Community you
know there's a really vibrant online community
of so many different blogs and Facebook pages
and things like that so I think you know before we
launched the kickstarter campaign we really tried
to reach out to to editors of blogs and you know
create personal relationships with people that
you know could help us get the word out and
so that was that was one of the ways that we
did that and then also reaching out to you know
anyone else that we thought kind of had a stake
in the message that we're trying to get out there
so any kind of environmental blog you know design
blogs architecture blogs you know any any other
subject matter that was touched by this story
We reached out to and we did a lot of you know
for film courage as well we did a lot of kind of
guest blogs and you know making sure that we could
provide great photos and great content to kind of
offer to these people and say you know this is
the story that we have going on use whatever you
want you know and help us kind of get the word out
there and I think that helps a lot we got you know
we ended up getting picked up by I think o.com and
you know Mother Nature Network and a few bigger
blogs that really helped us Sund Dam's Channel
blog and the kickstarter blog actually was was
was huge so it it's interesting Kickstarter itself
is is a platform for Discovery I mean I think you
found out about us through kick Kickstarter but
it just by putting it on Kickstarter we actually
a whole new group of people became aware of the
project which was really exciting but I would
definitely I guess ADV like if I were to give
advice to a a similar like an you know another
indie film that was trying to raise money on
Kickstarter I would definitely suggest that don't
do don't do it right off the bat you know wait a
little while develop you know your plan and make
some connections and then also get a lot of the U
media to accompany your your campaign like M was
saying with like great pictures and and videos and
things like that because it helps sell the story
a lot more and and plus if you you know show up
basically with some stuff that you can can show
and point to and say you know we've already you
know done this or I don't know you know it it
helps people with confidence knowing that it's
going to get made and yeah and I think too the
message with you know Kickstarter it's it's not
necessarily so much you know asking for money it's
more about like look at this great thing we're
doing that you can be a part of and so I think
it's really kind of tapping into that inspiration
factor and you know as much as people can kind of
do that I think it will be successful well mhm
one one last I guess piece of advice probably
is to so one thing that we did that maybe I would
do differently next time is just our rewards you
know we didn't anticipate how many people would be
donating and so some of our rewards took so much
time or or energy to fulfill that you know and
and for for us it was okay because we were still
relatively small project and campaign but for some
of the larger films out there they you know they
could find that they spend hours you know just
fulfilling days fulfilling Kickstarter rewards
you know so it's just something to to keep in mind
for filmmakers I think yeah that's a great point
and I'm wondering too when things weren't maybe
happening or maybe you didn't have days like that
but I know for our campaign there were days where
it was just dead in the water and it's like okay
time's running out what did you do to try to drum
up noise about the project I mean I think yeah
whenever there was sort of a lull it would be
like okay you know I remember before we started
the project or the the campaign I wrote down a
list of every single blog or you know mailing
list or newsletter or personal contact I mean
down to like the colleges that we went to just
like the alumni networks I mean any any community
that I could think of to reach out to and was kind
of just crossing them off the list so if you know
whenever we hit a la I was kind of like okay so
what new blog can I write and you know helpful
cuz my background is in writing so it was easy
for me to kind of like figure out a new angle and
and write a blog but you know it was kind of just
like okay what what else can I put out there just
to keep putting stuff out yeah I think definitely
the plan about you know having a regular sort of
schedule of of blogs so even if we knew that in
advance that there would be four or five blogs
that we're already willing to either write about
us or let us do a guest blog we would you know
say okay well can we do it this day because we
didn't want to have five come out on one day
and then have a week where there wasn't any so
we tried to Pace it yeah and I think you know it's
important to remember too that it's it's great to
you know start small I mean a lot of the press
coverage that we got you know started off being
really small kind of local blogs and newsletters
that you know someone would see it and be like
oh that's cool and they write about it for their
thing and it kind of got you know would the the
reach became greater and greater but we started
pretty small and I think you know it's not like
you need to have a contact with the New York Times
in order to you know make a successful campaign
you can you can start with who you know sure what
about for people though that maybe either aren't
willing to write or aren't a skilled writer such
as yourself and a lot of people approach us and I
think sometimes they're afraid because they know
people might read it and they don't know if it'll
come across correctly or you know what would you
say to someone that it has that fear of writing we
dealt with so many people like that I mean I would
say that there's there there's more ways than
just words to tell a story so I mean if someone's
really visual or you know maybe someone could like
do a cartoon or I don't know I mean there's so
many different ways to get a message across that
doesn't have to necessarily be in the written word
I mean it could be music or you know just really
kind of using creativity to think of different
methods I mean if they're filmmakers presumably
they do video blogs or something like that but
I would also say that I think any film is going
to be enhanced by having a good writer attached to
it so it's almost worth I mean you know maybe they
don't have access to a writer at the moment but
that's kind of something that I would think about
in advance is just like okay well there's going
to be a lot of things that need to be written you
know from the script to blogs to promotional
materials you know it's it's good to have at
least somebody you can rely on if if you're not
comfortable doing that yeah and of your under
200 backwards it was like what 9 196 or something
like that were they people that you knew were they
from your college or were they family and friends
or who were they I'd say maybe like maybe 20 to
30% were people that we knew you know either
friends who gave sort of like $10 a piece or
family members who were able to give a little bit
more but I'd say I mean a good bulk of the people
who donated I think were either part of the tiny
house Community or were excited for environmental
reasons or it kind of found us you know through
one of those blogs yeah I I mean I might even be
kind of a high estimate I it's hard to say but
maybe 20 to 30% of them maybe 20% of the money
I think might have been from people know because
people we knew we had a few large donations from
you know family or something like that but I I
don't know I mean I think I was surprised at how
many people we didn't know you know honestly and
I mean strangers who were backing sort of higher
levels which I never expected you know to have
a stranger sort of back at the $500 level or
something like that which yeah really it was
really great and and from all over the world
Australia lots of people from Europe and yeah it
was it was nice and you know the interesting thing
is when we first launched the kickstarter campaign
that was we had 300 fans on Facebook or something
like that and and just as a gauge of we we were
relatively still new as a project and and if we
had even waited 6 months from that point I think
it it would have been a different story you know
as far as we would had even more people we didn't
know you know cuz yeah it's all about I mean it's
amazing what you can do with the internet do you
think people realize how hard crowdfunding is I
mean Kickstarter and indigogo they're such sexy
sites and they see these beautiful trailers do
you think people just think oh I'll just put this
up and then strangers from all over the world will
find my I think that's exactly what people think
and they're wrong and a lot of those if people do
that then they you see a lot of things that don't
that don't make their goal like what was it you
found a great one they had this great project that
I I backed and I tweeted about it and I went back
a couple days later and they didn't have any more
backers I went back a couple weeks later and they
didn't have any more backers I was like that means
to me that they didn't even put in the effort to
con their friends into backing their project
which means that maybe they should look into
how crowdfunding Works more and try again because
it's almost a full-time job yeah there a lot of
refreshing of the the web page this is our second
anyone else anyone else yeah and our first one was
definitely a full-time job and and so is this one
it's it's really hard and you have to do a lot of
research and you have to do a lot of contacting
people and blogs and you know newspapers and
things that aren't ever going to contact you back
but you have to contact them anyway and just in
Cas just in case and it's it's very difficult and
you have to have a a base to start with too I read
somewhere that you know your number of Facebook
friends is directly proportional to how well your
Kickstarter does and Facebook is definitely the
number one source for our pledges so attractive
since last year Kickstarter put in a great new
dashboard and you can see where everything's come
from coming from so that's a great time waster
too because you can look at that and be like oh
you know 37% from Twitter I I better tweet more
so right mostly it's just trying to get the word
out and trying to get people to repost it retweet
and that sort of thing because that's it's really
eyeballs getting eyeballs on the project on the
on the video because if they like the video then
then that's could push them over and explaining to
people that even if you don't have money to pledge
which I totally understand sharing it is worth
something if you tweet it if you Facebook it and
then if you do that again in a couple days that
really helps the people and I do that a lot with
projects that I'm I'm not going to back all share
them because I think they're wonderful and I want
them to happen so and having new content to post
so that you not posting the same thing over and
over again really helps we were a little pressed
for time with this with this one we would have
preferred to have had a couple of different videos
ready to go so we could you know release them we
did a second video after with Barry Boswick who's
in the movie that was that was a lot of fun and
we have a couple written but you know it's been
hard to line people's schedules up so it would
have been nice if we were smart to to to plan
more time yeah to have had the whole campaign but
we had to pull the trigger because of the timing
of our of our first screening so so what do you
found has been the biggest draw besides Facebook
to getting people that are outside your Social
Circle family and friends to donate what's been
the best approach well for our last Kickstarter we
were very lucky to get a lot of blog attention and
that definitely was what every time we we got we
featured on a new blog like boing boing or Nerdist
or Laughing Squid it would just it would just
surge because it was it was eyeballs on it that
hadn't seen it before and that people were excited
about the idea and it also had the legitimacy of
an outside Source saying hey look at this thing
as opposed to the person themselves yeah right hey
look at me over here so that really really helped
and in terms of not having the same sort of media
attention having Barry Boston retweet and or he
does not doesn't have a Twitter but Facebooking
sharing the the video that he did really helped
Neil G shared it which was helpful Simon Hellberg
who's in the movie shared it which is helpful and
just having anyone share it is helpful anyone
with reach we we had a a little article in the
Nerdist today and and there was a definite
little there's been a bump today that that
really went along with that we were featured and
we did an interview on the Nerdist on Friday that
land that landed and and that gave us a little
bit of a bump as well so it's it's just about
getting the word out and people people hearing
your message and hopefully liking what you have
to say well what sounds good in theory but then
it actually didn't work too well huh well I'll
look at the kickstarter and oh gosh there hasn't
been a pledge for 4 hours and I'll go and and do
a lot of social media and nothing happens so it's
really hard to know what does work working yeah
what else doesn't work what else doesn't work oh
I sent an email to every single person from that
is on my Facebook from my hometown and I people
just don't read Facebook messages is part of it
but I think I got one response so that you know
people say personal appeals but I think emails
may be better than Facebook messages right phone
calls phone calls okay text messages explaining to
your grandmother how to open her email so she can
share it with her friend right do you think there
are certain times of day that are more receptive
to tweets I mean I know DAV has always said 5:00
seems like a good time is that getting off and and
I noticed in the morning too which is terrible you
have to get up in the morning we like to work late
yeah that's the problem too is a lot of times 3:00
a.m. I'm tweeting and Facebooking up a storm
and nobody cares sure well there's people in
Germany yes yes our foreign fan base we have we
have fans in Indonesia so true that's true the
film is played there so John can you give us a few
reasons why people succeed at cop fun [Music] you
know I'd say the easiest blanket statement would
be because they set up their project properly you
know and they strategized it well and they you
know it and what people need to think about is
that crowdfunding is very much like making a film
you know that it's a lot of prep you know and all
the the more work you do in the prep it's going
to benefit you in production that if you Prep
properly the production will be much smoother
and if you don't Prep properly you're going to
be scrambling you know and then there's post
you there's the follow through so you know I
think being realistic about who your audience is
and how much of an audience you have and making
that you know sync with your goal and then also
thinking about your audience and potentially what
they'd want from you in terms of rewards and
and providing those in a create and providing
creative and interesting rewards you know having a
compelling call to action and compelling video and
being personable and and and and then you know
working it or you know having enough people on
board to help work it during the campaign you
know and that's you know what I would say you
know do you think people can take their social
media as a collective of the project and kind
of break it down and say well I'm assuming if we
have X amount of Facebook followers x amount of
Twitter followers realistically we're going to
be able to get this much you think that works
I me I think you have to be very pessimistic
you know and really look at conventional online
conversion you know and online conversion is you
know at best 1% so you know which is very so if
you have 10,000 followers say which I almost
do say so I have 8,000 followers on Twitter
and if I convert 1% of those to even look at my
Kickstarter page right so what is 1% of 10,000
you know I'm a math guy so 10% is 1,000 so 1%
is 100 not much right so if I get if I do a 1%
conversion from my followers so that's 100 and if
I get 1% of those people to then convert from the
conversion because the the first conversion is the
click the second conversion is the buy that's one
person out of my 10,000 followers who are going
to contribute now I think I'm probably going to
do better than that but if I really want to be
conservative that's what you're looking at so
yes you can use your followers but you have to be
very conservative about what realistic about who
you're going to convert now I probably you know
will have a higher conversion rate because I feel
like you know I like to I feel like I followed
my you know 8020 Rule and that you know I feel
like I provide a lot of value to my followers and
I think I've maybe engendered Goodwill amongst
them I like to think and so and I know there's
certain people that I can call on to act you
know and I've contributed to campaigns Etc so you
know I think you know you have to so it's not an
easy calculation let me just put it that way it's
not just saying oh I have 8,000 people so 8,000
people will contribute or 4,000 will contribute
and Kickstarter says the average is $70 so then
4,000 * 70 is is $4,280 so I'm going to set my
goal it I'm going to be conservative and set
my goal at 200,000 you know that's crazy town you
know you're not that's it's not going to work like
that.